welcome back to the iced coffee hour i'm
jared polin from
froknowsphoto.com and this podcast has
made
two hundred and twenty seven thousand
dollars one uh 227 thousand dollars
and 12 cents
close uh 190
000. that's the closest one we've had
yet actually all right good that was
better than what my first guess was
going to be was going to be about 137
000 but i'm like
two years roughly
a little more good thanks so much for
making it out man we really appreciate
it yeah no problem this is also the
latest podcast we have ever filmed it's
10 15 p.m on a friday night we really
appreciate it friday night in vegas yeah
this is what we do have you seen my room
no
so
yeah it's it's at the rio okay which is
not it
it's an older hotel it's a yeah you're
getting a good deal you put it down
though that's the person
making connections but they have villas
over there okay the palazzo suite i
think it's like four or five thousand
square feet there's five bathrooms
there's
uh four showers and they all have
uh
saunas in them
there's two
hot tubs one on each balcony it's it's
stupid but you have that all to yourself
yeah it's just me one one backpack and a
roller bag with camera gear
who gave you this room uh the caesar's
people
i reached out and i was this is how i've
done a lot of things you ask and it's
not the typical i'm an influencer give
me free [ __ ] stuff
it's hey i'm coming to town
i asked a friend
and they connected me with these people
and they have a whole influencer
department they're like oh well where
would you like to stay i'm like well the
thing that i'm doing is over by the rio
and they're like that's perfect
well we'll see what we can do and
they're like here's a villa
and it's massive it's the coolest thing
so what do you have to do in return for
that i did some insta stories and i'll
and just for fun i'll i'll make a crib
style
video they're not paying me yeah it says
it's a fifteen thousand dollar night
room fifteen thousand dollars now
you know that's how they say it and no
one pays that though because gamblers
yes for the high rollers or the the
concierge lady was like well for
celebrities like you i'm like
i make youtube videos um
what do i have to do so
the making a crib style video is good
i can say
what let's think of some clickbaity
titles right
what a fifteen thousand fifteen thousand
dollar a night tour of a vegas hotel
room i mean people will watch that stuff
all day and so how did you get the
influencer department are you reaching
out to hotels or is there like some like
so i asked a friend maverick you see the
maverick helicopter stuff lying around
yes so they've always been awesome we
flew with them for canon was doing an
event and they put us up there to fly
and to doors open and shooting photos
out of it um so i reached out to the guy
from there because he was a follower of
my channel as well and i was like do you
know anybody that would
have rooms that wants to do some content
and he got back to me and he's like i
know these people they got on the phone
and i'm like look i i don't i don't
gamble i don't drink
i'm looking for a cool spot
i don't mind paying like give me you
want a discount for a cool room i don't
care that's cool that's fine i'll make
some content they're like well we love
doing this stuff so how about we do this
and you'll just make some some videos
and like
some insta stories i'm like yeah sure
i've been doing it all wrong it's all
about asking
it's about for me it's been building a
network of people so you can always be
like a super connector and know someone
who knows someone and know someone and
it's not about i hate that
i'm an influencer you know on instagram
thing and give me free [ __ ] it's it's
not a it's not about that i just asked
i'm like i i would like a cool room if
if you give me a discount
i'm so worried i'd come off the wrong
way like i'd be getting pokey with jack
and it'd be like hey by the way here's
my follower account on instagram look at
that what can i get you literally did
that i didn't say that no but we went to
pokey and you're like whoa i'm posting
you up on my instagram no check it out
no i mean
he gave me a free pokeball i forget why
it was it was free
yeah it was free and then i said i'll
tag you because i was like that's really
cool and they said i don't have an
instagram
and you should say i think you said
something like to the tune of just get
an instagram i'll tag you and just check
it the next day yeah that's what you
said because you it's fun to see the
comments because every time we'll tag a
place i look at their latest picture and
everyone's like who's here from graham
graham sent me it's like you know 50
comments like that it's just it's cool
and i go and like all of them yeah so
before before we get too ahead of
ourselves guys okay do you have a
microphone yes yeah can you believe the
treatment i get here when i had a
podcast when we used to do the live
podcast we always never gave our guy
over there a microphone just for fun so
we could always say you don't have a
microphone you're not allowed to talk i
think i like that better actually
yeah i have the worst camera though and
people always complain about this thing
we purposely don't put a card in the
camera because this is a really old
camera and uh it aggravates the audience
actually alex is a huge fan of yours
huge you say this ever i don't but this
is the truth i i think he was most
excited to see you
we were all excited to see you were you
yes did you google me yes
just kidding
um no that's cool i asked jeeves you i i
reached alex
a while back and it was cool that he's
like oh i've been following you for a
long time like like when i started in
2010 he's
almost as long as that i want to um
actually say something really cool here
uh so jared used to have a podcast
called rawtalk and i was a huge fan i i
was like hey man why aren't you doing
the podcast anymore and we can get into
that later but
uh something cool that maybe jared
doesn't know
um he came to chicago to do a live
uh episode yeah at some some uh comedy
place yeah yeah and i was actually uh i
was like 18 or something and like i
didn't have a credit card and so like i
emailed jared i was like hey jared like
i want to come to your thing but like i
don't have a credit card can i give you
cash and jared to my surprise he
responded and he said um
hey yeah yeah man just uh you know show
them the email or whatever and uh i
think it was like 10 bucks to get in
and uh i think i made it eight he came
out or yeah let me explain why later
and uh
long story short i gave you a free
ticket i hope he gave me a free ticket
and thank god i helped switch the
cameras you did yes so look at me now
guys look look look at me now you were
the one that i yelled at probably 15
times like are you recording yes are you
recording because i always do them like
are you sure you hit the button because
if you hit it too quick on those nikons
back in the day it would not actually
hit record it would not do it yeah
that's cool god thankful thankfully i
gave him a ticket yeah i actually never
got in no imagine he i charged him eight
dollars
[Music]
so for those who don't know jared he
makes content online about photography
video uh what the latest cameras are
coming out anything uh to do with you
know creating on a camera jared
basically covers it all and you've been
doing it for like 13 years that was when
your first episo or first ever video was
uploaded to youtube so long 20 2010
was the first well that's when i
officially launched but yeah i i you
know how you do that
started it gives you that starter you
start in 2008 i'm like no i started on
youtube in 2008 because i thought with
this thing called youtube i could get
porn on it
did you really yeah i thought that's
what it was i mean i didn't know you
searched first before making an account
but that's what i searched you made an
account first
i'm gonna sign up first and then i don't
remember i honestly don't remember but
that was my first recollection of
youtube was like can you find porn on
this and that was back then that was a
long time ago um but no i started in
2010 yeah did you find the right
websites though after that i mean that
was easy
look up until that point yeah i bought a
computer with my bar mitzvah money when
i was 13. um and i got really good at
aol and chat rooms and all that stuff it
was before your time
like how old are you uh 41 okay now
unfortunately not unfortunately but you
know um you could have told me 30 i
would have guessed that yeah yeah i
appreciate it
yeah if i shaved my head
it's the fitness routine
no i i appreciate that
but yeah yeah lots of videos 2010. um
it's been good it's been good how do you
get started doing that youtube so yeah
no photography in general photography
it's always a passion of yours same
reason as i started youtube so i'll
start with the photography thing i
i was in junior high school 13 years old
and i was watching one of the basketball
games and there the yearbook
photographers were taking pictures
during practice and nothing was actually
happening and i'm like why are they
taking pictures now like there's no
action going on
and so instead of telling them that they
suck i went home i borrowed my mom's
point-and-shoot camera came back to the
next game
sat on the baseline and did what i
thought would work
and i just had the timing i could
anticipate the moment and capture it and
we got the roll of film back and it was
like
oh even with a point-and-shoot camera i
was like able to anticipate because
there's a delay and i i worked with the
delay and boom got the shots and so
that's how i started taking pictures
and i just built from there before you
know you could search online and i was
not smart enough to be like oh there's a
library thing called a library i could
go there and get books on photography i
didn't yeah so it was all self-taught it
was film it was just trial and error
just slow you know you take a roll of
film takes you a week to shoot it and
then you get it developed and then you
don't remember what settings you had so
you don't know how to actually get
better so it was a lot of auto shooting
and
it was all training me to get to the
youtube world i guess got it
oh go for it i was gonna say the reason
i started youtube is i was i was
watching
uh
a video that came up about a lens
and i thought the guy gave absolutely
terrible information i'm like you this
has 36 000 views and you gave this
information and so instead of telling
him he sucked in the comments which is
what most people do today i was like
i have a camera
it shoots video
i can sit in front of it and
do this let me let me try which is what
we tell everybody when they say things
and comments like let me actually try to
do this and i did and
that was one of the reasons i started
and my hope was that i would actually
get more jobs out of it and what ended
up happening is i got a lot of questions
every time i got a question i'm like
well if this person has this question
that means a ton of other people do
youtube is not for porn it's for
searching for for information and
i'm gonna put this stuff up there and so
every day i started making videos
just one a day or two a day and it
averaged out to one a day for seven
years wow
but it was a different world like
youtube in 2010 was it was about putting
out a lot of content i was basically a
daily vlogger before vlogging was even a
thing
how long did it take until you started
seeing substantial growth and realizing
that like okay this maybe monetarily is
something i can do as a person like what
were you doing for money
i was shooting weddings yeah i was
living at home which was helpful right
i'm 30
no not 30 yet i was like 28 29 living at
home and
struggling as a photographer through my
20s and i shot weddings which i'm not a
big fan of weddings but shooting them
can be lucrative you know you clear 2
500 to 3 000 on a on a on a wedding and
you're like i got paid this much money
to go take pictures that's great but i
never made a lot of money um and that's
why i started at the you partly starting
youtube to try to get more jobs and that
didn't happen i got more followers um
the the growth was slow
i didn't hit a million subscribers until
like a couple years ago
it was a slow growth but i i still
thought
you know 800 views on a video well
that's pretty good a thousand views and
it just climbed slowly 25 000
subscribers you know 26 000 subscribers
it just was a slow build and i think
it was probably good that i didn't ever
have a video hit a million until about
seven years in
because if you got a million on your
first video and then you try to chase
that every time you're chasing the wrong
thing and so it's a slow build and i
thought i was hot at 25 000 subscribers
and there was no money at the beginning
it was 2010 they didn't have a a program
yet
and
the the story of how when they announced
it i was like top 2500 youtube channels
at the time and wouldn't there weren't a
lot of us but first we want to thank our
sponsor titan jack i've been trying to
figure out where to invest my money but
with everything going on in the market
right now it's so hard and i don't know
what to do
sure alex you could try to do everything
yourself or you could use titan titan is
the first investment app that gives you
an award-winning investment team who
strategically manages her wealth
regardless of what's happening in the
world and all it takes is 100 to get
started all you have to do is deposit
your money select your portfolio and
titan's team of analysts will allocate
your money for you and with titan you
can get updates about decisions being
made with your money and you can even
ask your team questions to learn more
all within the app listen guys i know
that the market is all over the place
right now and it can seem very scary but
that's why there's no better time than
now to let the experts take over and
handle that volatility for you and right
now if you use my url which is linked
down below in the description it's
titan.com
ich you can get your first three months
of active investment management for free
again guys that's titan.com
ich for zero in management fees thank
you so much titan and back to the
podcast they announced the the the
partner program and i submitted and i
got denied i got an email back and
they're like
no
and i'm like what do you mean i've got
26 000 subscribers i'm one of the
largest photo channels out there i
really think you should reconsider and
this i just hit reply to the email
the day later came back was like okay
and i was like
oh i'm a youtube partner i made 18 cents
on something and so it just
i just started making a couple bucks
there but the
the biggest uh influx was i
worked at a store called allen's camera
um a mom-and-pop camera store that still
exists today been around since the 70s
okay 4401 new falls road i used to work
there yeah um
and alan who passed away a couple years
ago
um
there was always this advertising money
so when he would buy gear like from
canon
every three dollars he would spend he
would get or yeah he would get a dollar
back to do newspaper ads or something
and he would never use it so it was just
sitting there and he's like if you can
get
them to
approve canon to approve online ads
which they didn't at the time in 2010
they're like they didn't believe that
that was a good way of advertising which
was how dumb can you be why would you
they would spend like five thousand
dollars doing an ad in a newspaper
it's like that's not targeted that's
you're pissing into the wind and so i
was able to talk them into it and he
said if you can get them to approve it
we can split all of the money
and i got a 24 000 check the first time
that happened so he had like 48 000 in
ad money that would end up going away if
he didn't use it in time and so now i
did the work he signed off on it they
approved it i mean to get 24 grand at
the beginning was just
awesome plus he allowed me to go to the
store and do unboxings and sniff tests i
started sniffing gear what is that
i would uh you know how people sniff
wine and yeah garyvee would sniff wine
right i borrowed it from him
okay he sniffed wine i'm like i'm gonna
sniff gear and say it smells like
something so it's i would smell a lens
and be like you know it smells like a
lincoln log you know it's like a really
good smell it passes the sniff test
once i did it smells like uh don't buy
it
which
he didn't like when i said don't buy it
but i was being honest yeah so yeah
that's that's that
the money wasn't there wasn't a lot of
money at the beginning did you go to
college or did you get straight from
high school wedding photography i did a
two-year photography school okay uh i
was
i was a homebody i wasn't i wasn't ready
to go away i wish the parents maybe
would have pushed me
but i don't regret past things ever i
don't like playing revisionist history
because you don't know where you would
have ended up otherwise so i'm not a big
fan of being like well i should have
done this actually you chose to do this
yeah you go with it are you really doing
that else are you really making it oh
bailey chewed a wire and there's been
like no you guys have probably noticed
at the audience there's been noise on
the podcast a little bit no i'm trying
to finish you know mess around with
stuff so the noise goes away and you
know what i think i finally got it to go
away so i think you were you were
getting to the point of okay you were
talking about college and then also
maybe like when the money on youtube
started
getting to be rolling in yeah yeah
rolling in 26
you know it was it wasn't a lot of money
at the beginning but uh there were some
the allen's camera thing helped a lot 24
grand right up front was was pretty
helpful uh companies start coming out of
the woodworks they want to pay you i
really didn't accept much
back then it was like you can give me
gear to review
and i'll review it but i'm going to say
what i want to say
and
you have no say in what's happening um
so there wasn't there wasn't a ton of
money i think the first year i may have
made
48 000 or something or 50 grand and that
came from a lot of the allen stuff and i
started selling t-shirts 10 days in
yeah now i'm thinking back it's a long
time ago um
10 days in i'm like i'm going to start
selling merch because i used to tour
with bands and that's how they made
money so i'm like i'm going to make a
shirt i got i shoot raw and i would i
would have the shirts made i would only
charge like 11.99 i may have made three
or four bucks but i took all of the
profits put it back in the shirts
because when you can order more shirts
it costs less money right you make more
money in the long run so i started to
add a shirt color or two and i would set
it all up in my brother's bedroom
because he moved out he got married he
was gone and i had my bedroom and then
over here i used this as my office and
um
and and i would i would ship everything
myself fold the shirts write the the
envelopes out go to the post office ship
everything and i just started making a
little bit of money here and there when
he sure is shipping out
everything at the beginning it was maybe
five a week okay um not a lot you know
it's kind of funny because i i had a
printer i drilled a hole i cut a hole in
the wall so i could pass the cables
before wireless brakes and i had the
printer run from the imac in the other
room the cable and it would
automatically print when a sale came in
it was like two in the morning and i'm
getting woken up and i'm like this is
amazing this is awesome and then what
would happen is you start selling five a
night and then you would i'm like yeah i
need to move the printer so i moved the
printer back into the into my brother's
room and uh my dad used to like walking
down the hallway in the morning just to
see because he didn't understand what a
youtuber did like how do you make money
he's like i don't know what to do he's
like i don't know what you should be
doing i'm like this is what i do and
then you would physically see an order
come out
and be like wow you're actually making
money and so it started to be like 20
shirts 100 shirts and we started i
started sell a lot of shirts because i
would promote it in the video i'm like
guys you want to show the world that you
shoot raw it was a controversial
controversial thing about
back then with raw vs jpeg
people embraced it and they ordered it
and then i moved the entire i went from
one shirt to three shirts different
colors then i put racks in the basement
and i expanded how many shirts i had and
for my 30th birthday i did a three shirt
deal for 30 bucks and and i and i
printed all the orders out and put all
the envelopes on the floor and my dad
would throw me shirts i would be like i
need a large blue i need a give me three
large blues or whatever and we had like
100 different packages on the floor
so it was just making money and selling
doing merch
how much were you making
i mean so i started to sell the shirts
for 11.99 then i
i just wanted see it was more branding
right um i think one year when shirts
were really good it's like 200 grand wow
on on
profit there's no that wasn't all profit
oh got it um but it was generating that
much in in selling shirts there was a it
was a it was a slog you know i i
promoted it quite a bit yeah and i
didn't want to just over promote that um
but i raised the price i think i made
them 14.99 and then i was able to get
shirts uh
get blanks for four bucks
get it directly sent to the printer
print at a local printer it's a mistake
a lot of people make is they print
somewhere else and they have to ship
them everything now you're spending 200
on shipping it just eats away at your
profit so if you keep it local you go
pick it up or they drop it off to you
you're saving on shipping right there
so it's just every little buck you can
save there was really helpful wow
i think i remember an interesting story
about your shirt uh this is a long time
ago but didn't you yeah get kicked out
of six flags i didn't get led into six
flags in the first place why um the
woman
at the gate that was running security
was like that's a dirty shirt and i'm
like
what are you talking about i believe i'm
an idiot an idiot i understand there's a
double entendre it could go any
different way that's the whole point of
it but i'm like it's a photography term
and i have my logo is on the back it
says frono's photo she's like you know
what's wrong with it i'm like i i don't
know what's wrong with it you explained
i filmed it yeah i was that guy i filmed
the whole thing and they got their
supervisor and like well she says you
can't come in i'm like like you could
you're more than welcome to go get
another shirt from your car like who
travels with multiple shirts i'm like
the multiple shirts in the car are all i
shoot raw shirts and my buddy had a nice
shoe raw shirt on too because he liked
it yeah they're like well you can you're
more than welcome to go buy another
shirt in the store
like all right let's go buy a shirt in
the store and then i saw let it roll i'm
like that's a drug reference guys you
have let it roll you have i like it
rough
really
you're a kid you're you're telling me i
shoot raw is bad those are like guns i'm
like but i'm telling you it's not guns
like i it's a
google it like
and so i go in there and
i go to the kids rack
little girls rack find the smallest
shirt it says
it says uh
what'd it say print something princess
something perfect princess or something
and had cupcakes on it and so i wore
that all day i'm like you guys are just
gonna see me in a belly shirt all day if
that's what you want that's what i did i
wore that all day and then they gave me
my shirt back at the end of the day and
then i i was hoping that i get an
apology from them or something for
putting them on blast but no it got
picked up by a bunch of people it did it
was just [ __ ] though it's like it's
a shirt i'm like i've been to disney
with this couldn't you just turn the
shirt inside out i wouldn't allow it it
was a first great question that i was
like i'll just turn it inside they're
like you might reverse it oh my god now
you're telling me i'm an apple
like now you're telling me i'm i'm not a
man of mine you're going to buy a tiny
little bit it didn't say it's a perfect
little princess
and it was a it was a mint if you could
pull that up on the internet i don't
think you can draw rogue in it but it's
out there perfectly it was like perfect
little princess and cupcakes on it with
sparkles
i still have it jeez do you ever wear it
still nah it's not going to fit around
the arms anymore
you should bring it back i'll bring it
back it's in the closet if you could
return it go return it to them i haven't
been back i don't like i don't like six
flags never like flags not a big fan of
waiting in line for brides anyway but
first i want to thank our sponsor ftx us
ftx is one of the most complete crypto
and finance apps out there it allows
users to buy and sell nfts with no fees
whatsoever ftx is one of the largest
crypto exchanges out there in terms of
trading volume and daily users and
they're valued at over 8 billion dollars
you might have heard of the ftx brand
through their partnerships with people
like tom brady coachella or the miami
heat stadium most crypto exchanges
charge two to three dollar fees for
every single transaction that you make
but with ftx you can trade as much as
you want and it's all free and their
founder sam bankman freed plans to give
away 99 of what he personally makes to
charity they also make dollar cost
averaging easy with things like
reoccurring buys where they can pull
money directly from your bank account on
a weekly bi-weekly or on a monthly basis
and invest it for you automatically they
even offer a crypto friendly debit card
allowing you to spend crypto at millions
of merchants worldwide so start trading
crypto and nfts with no fees today by
downloading the ftx app with the link
down below in the description again guys
the link is down below in description to
get started trading crypto and nfts with
no fees today thank you so much ftx and
back to the podcast so how did your your
business life progress when did when did
youtube really the dose start to come in
do you still do photography outside of
youtube if so why good question and also
okay i'll i'll say
questions those are those are good yeah
so money um
i think second year was like 84 000 and
that
was a lot of merch and a couple of
advertising things but the real growth
came two years in uh i created a product
digital product education the fro knows
photo guide to getting out of auto
um
was three hours
of education that was fun and
informative it wasn't boring [ __ ]
that was my whole thing it's fun and
informative it has to be and i wanted to
create a product and right around this
time i was looking to to buy a house
my first my first property i never
wanted to rent because rent to me was
like just lighting money on fire i'm
like why would i just do that when i
could save up and buy a house so it's
2012 uh interest rates are super low at
that time not as low as they were a
couple months ago it was like 3.375
on a 30-year fixed and i didn't have
enough money for the down payment i had
half
my dad my mom passed away a few years
prior and she had a pension he's like uh
she would want this i'm gonna
i'll help you and then i released the
phonos photo guide to getting out of
auto and after two weeks the first check
i got was twenty six thousand dollars
and i was like dad i got it like i got
it and there were very few people doing
online sales of digital products back in
2012 right um i figured out how to do it
it was like only four gigabytes you know
you got to keep it pretty small
people that dial up we we i had dvds
produced
that could
the coolest thing was in the package
there were two dvds you got two you got
one that was computer ready so it was a
rom i guess was that what we called them
back in the day rom's read-only memory
so so that would play in the in the
computer but there was also one that
would play in a dvd player because i was
just like i need to do both just in case
so people could have the files and then
they could have the actual dvd and we
were selling them on sale for everything
was 47 bucks
67 was the the launch
what it was crossed that out 47 and it
was just doing two to five thousand
dollars a day
through the end of the year that's crazy
and it was just through my list and i
may have only had twenty five thousand
follow uh instagram instagram didn't
exist i only had uh 25 000 people on my
email list at the time but it was just
through youtube right i'd make a video
every video is an advertisement for
myself i tell people that every video
you make is an ad for you and it's all
right to ask for the sale you have to at
some point they understood i'm like guys
i'm giving you all this free content if
you want to support me if you'd like to
support me or you want to learn as well
to help you get out of auto i got this
product and so a lot of people that have
followed me for two years are like i i
don't need to know how to get out of
auto i'm already there but i'll support
you i ordered i ordered your digital
download and one of the things i also
did is i did a camera giveaway too and i
had to learn the whole raffle thing and
what's legal and what's not yes because
it's sweepstakes right right yeah the
whole thing is
you have to do no purchase necessary
option two
but i did do this and
it just it helped influx sales because
people like i have a chance of winning
one of these awesome cameras and i get
this education and so it was just dude
it was
it was stupid i remember the making
showing my dad my tax return and he's
like i've never made that
in a year ever
and it's it's just crazy that it's a
digital product so what was it back then
600 grand 700 grand you're doing like 2
000 a day there's no overhead on that
right very little well very little it
was all it was digital sales i think i
think i made like
like 400 000 bucks or something at the
end of the year yeah and
he was just like
holy [ __ ] it's like what's the scam
no he was he's like i finally get he's
like i didn't know what the hell you've
been doing in your room all these yeah
you know in the backyard i would sit in
the backyard i would i would tackle
mannequins that said i shoot jpeg i
would take the mannequin to the
firehouse and talk them into shooting it
with a fire hose you know just doing
weird other people weren't doing sniff
tests went i didn't do wind tunnel tests
yet at that point i just literally blow
on the lens and say it passes or fails
just something stupid yeah just
something to make people go what the
[ __ ] does that even mean yeah right
because everybody else was doing boring
[ __ ]
and i'm just
they would say i'm like the howard stern
of the photo world yeah that's not
afraid to say it like i don't look like
him
[ __ ] you no no it's a good thing
his sister is a follower
ellen his sister watches my videos and
is a really good photographer and howard
became a photographer for a minute as
well before he got into painting he's
taller that's what i meant oh i i just
thought the hair kind of
yes maybe not i don't know he's he has
different features he's taller than me
we're jewish i mean if you're trying i'm
jewish too and so is graham we're all
jewish yeah yeah
i'm half yeah alex is not sorry but
anyways uh so you were selling a course
to go off of auto what is to go off auto
get out for those that don't get out of
auto so basically um
you know that you ever look at the
d80 or the 80d over there you know the
green mode up top this green square
that's always auto on all the cameras
and so the whole point is to get people
out of that mode and into manual so they
understand shutter speed aperture iso
shutter speed do you want me to go into
all this yes i'll do it yeah shutter
speed controls uh like
you have a fast shutter speed is going
to freeze motion a slow shutter we in in
this in this video we actually used a
swing set as an example at the park
while people looked at me i'm like it's
a [ __ ] park i pay taxes i can be here
your little sh your kid not shitty kid
your little kid can go swing over there
i got here first literally i said that
to people slower shutter speeds
give you some blur so i try to teach
people the cause and effect if you do
this this is going to happen
aperture how much light you're letting
in iso is the brain teach all that stuff
so helping people take control of their
camera get into manual so that they can
control the light
i didn't understand this it took me a
decade to get out of auto with film
so my whole selling point was look i've
done all the
hard work and i've condensed this into
something that i guarantee you you will
get out of auto after three hours of
watching this and you can get your money
back if you really want your money back
like i don't care if someone asks for
their money back giving their money back
right um and so that does that explain
what get out of auto is it gets people
out of auto so that they can take
control of their camera and they did
there's people that that always say that
like i started with that because i
wanted to make it i like to say that i'm
you know the mix of howard stern and bob
ross uh meets mr rogers because i love
mr rogers was he he showed things he
didn't just say it he showed it and i
was a montessori kid when growing up
like
you know montessori school it's a great
way of learning it's hands-on you don't
know that you're learning because it's
it's a different classroom environment
you learn through play you learn through
like okay you
jared go get a bowl you're giving out
snacks right you got the
the the pretzels they're like okay give
two to each person
okay so now you have to go talk to the
person in the class now you have to say
okay you can have two of those then you
have to make sure they have two of those
and if they don't you get to punch them
not true you didn't get to punch them
but just
montessori school stuff like that it's
like you learn by doing so i learn
that's how i learn i learned by watching
and doing and so that's how i wanted to
teach and so that's how i got people out
of auto and it works
they don't have to go to college really
i put i basically put my college out of
business people i i like to say i put
them out but people like me on the
internet who did education and sold
education basically put
votech schools for photography out of
business why spend 20 40 50 000
to learn the [ __ ] that i'm teaching you
for 60 seconds why but why spend two
years in school to learn things that you
could google it's like
yes it's a good question it doesn't make
any sense people think that they they
need to go because that's what
everybody's done before them
people say should i go to college for
photography and my answer is
no you shouldn't go just for photography
if you are going to go to a school go to
the biggest four-year school that you
can find because they have the most
athletics you can get involved you can
travel with them but don't go for
photography
minor in photography do video do audio
engineering do advertising do marketing
learn all of this [ __ ] that you can
because when you come out of school when
someone says can you shoot video yeah
can you edit video yeah do you know how
to take photos i do they're gonna
they're gonna hire you because you
you're you're a quadruple so many
threats you can do it all right so
that's that's what i tell people for
going to school but i would never just
go for a two-year photography school
anymore yeah how much was that for you
you said 50 grand it was 20 grand at the
time it was 1999 to 2001.
so that's when i went it was a two-year
school and i think it was twenty one
thousand dollars total my parents
still a lot of money back yeah i had
student loans and thankfully it wasn't a
ton and i did end up paying them all off
um
but yeah
you wanted to ask about the price of the
house you were talking about yeah yeah
cause you bought in 2012 which was like
a low i mean you could say low so i
bought into a place called fish town
it's like the brooklyn of of philly it's
just exploded 20 a year
for like many years now um
and i had a
i wanted to spend like 400 000 on a
place and it came down they were at like
450 and we ended up at four and a
quarter and uh i stretched because my
dad always said to me i i
you know
25 000
extra is like 80 bucks a month in the
grand scheme of things so don't
don't skimp out and so i got this place
it was the most expensive place on the
block at the time and now it's it's
worth close to eight
um because that area just has exploded
and now i rent that
because
i um
i ended up buying another place during
the pandemic getting super low interest
rate it was like three point two seven
five or something and then refined eight
months later because i got 2.7 wow
you got two seven yeah how
i don't know i asked did you have to put
any money down or anything or no i just
refined it it was two seven it was a
jumbo and someone took the jumbo at two
seven and i refunded i don't think there
was chase
okay yeah the original one
chase on this one yeah and the original
was wells fargo um
and then we we redid it and got 2.7
is what talk about a savings was like
800 800 bucks a month or so um
and yeah i basically refined every
property because i i bought the fro
factory
a couple years about six years ago
because i never wanted to rent i we
literally worked out of my loft the
house that i bought
it's a loft so it's a 120 year old
130 year old factory now that was an
elevator factory and i had the upstairs
place that was built for
the people that renovated they did a
double unit so 2140 square foot feet a
freight elevator opened up into the
place i basically bought the place from
big
that was a goal of mine i was i loved
big and i always wanted that place so
basically had the place from big um and
it was set up that i had keno flows the
lights
all set up my podcast table was my
kitchen table uh it's a poker table with
my logo on it and then you put the lid
on it so i could have dinner but it was
all set up to basically it was like a
studio but i lived upstairs right right
in the loft area um because i just
thought it was a waste of money to go
rent something and then a couple years
later as we started to expand and get
larger and i had two employees coming to
my house every morning and i'd roll out
of bed while they walked in the door
because they had the key and uh
these like you know we would save a lot
of time if we didn't have to break down
the lights every day and and do all this
so i started looking for a place
found a place in
what they call kensington which was big
in heroin at the time not as big anymore
in heroin and it's a mile and a half
from my place
and i bought that place
and that place i bought for 5.35
and it's a million bucks now
because there's a plot of land right
there it's just
i never intended to buy multiple
properties it's just was it just
happened so how many do you have now
three or four
during the pandemic uh right before the
pandemic
my friend showed me this cool
building
it's 5 000 square feet it's another loft
style building and i was like
oh that's pretty cool
and i know i didn't think about i wasn't
thinking about moving at all but if i
want to have a family and and grow i
didn't want to have a family in
a condo building
and so
i talked to some of my financial people
uh and i'm like i'm not looking for you
to give me approval i don't need you to
tell me yes or no
like i should do this or not i just need
to know financially am i
sound enough to purchase it was a
million dollar they wanted a million
fifty i'm like am i in the right place
can i do this and they're like
yeah
and so
i made an offer the day after doing a
walk through my realtor went and took a
look and he's like oh we'll make an
offer monday i'm like fat i'm like
someone's going to come in with way more
money than me
and and offer to buy this and he's like
well what do you want to what do you
want to offer them like make it a what i
call a [ __ ] you offer which
is a million bucks give them what they
want i mean if they ask for 10 you know
a million 50 and they walk away from a
million they're not serious and so
they took it and then like they got
three cash offers as soon as we signed
the deal wow there was no
realtor would ever say if you like it
let's wait the weekend
i don't know i don't know but they just
had a realtor's open house and i just
moved on it quick because i knew this
this is it's such a unique property that
there's so few of those left in the in
the country but philly has a lot of
lofts and they've all been converted to
a thousand square foot 1250 square foot
uh apartments and this place could be
turned into four different apartments if
you really wanted but i was just like do
it and then the pandemic hit
and i was under contract and people were
like are you still gonna buy it are you
still gonna do it and i called the
financial guys again they're like
are you good i'm like am i good to do
this they're like yeah nothing's changed
for you like you're fine you got your
youtube no one knew what was going to
happen yeah we didn't know what's going
to happen but i still went through with
it because why would i back out um so i
had the mortgage everything was there
and
i did that and i didn't move out
i closed on march
29
not today oh geez i clicked it's been
two years all right it's april 1st um so
it was like march 30th uh two years ago
and
didn't move until june 25th because i
still had my loft and it was the middle
of a pandemic i couldn't get movers you
couldn't do work on the place nothing
you couldn't get anything done um i got
people to rent my loft on a two-year a
two-year lease
3 500 bucks a month and i moved and it
was great what's your picture
500
what's my mortgage is uh
i was like 1800 bucks now
yeah well that's without taxes but it's
still it's still
i think i think i
make like 24 000 a year
off of it
it's cool and i'm not bragging for
people out this isn't bragging yeah
thanks for cutting to wait where's my
camera right there yeah not this isn't
bragging this is a financial podcast i
mean it's a coffee podcast i don't drink
coffee i didn't want to tell anybody but
i've never had a coffee really yeah
really so you also don't drink alcohol
or party i don't party i'll have a mixed
drink every once in a while i just don't
have any desire to drink or get
plastered or do drugs i just i've smoked
weed in the past and it's just like i
feel like an idiot the next day i feel
like i'm in a fog and i don't want to
feel dumb and it makes me feel dumb and
i don't want to do it yeah yeah but i'm
not bragging like it's not bragging it's
just
i worked my ass off to do it so it's
good man i like that so tell us a bit
about the uh about the look that you've
crafted the thing i'm just gonna pick my
hair because it needs to be poofed a
little bit
there we go
just
so this kind of reminds me of like the
dogecoin millionaire haircut like a
little bit if he if he poofed it out a
little bit more how much is his million
what's that worth now 300 grand did he
ever sell anything no
so tell us about the afro the hair
so
i had the hair a couple years before i
even had the idea for fro knows photo um
i just i've never had my hair grow
because i'm i'm jewish and i got jew
curls and if i let it go past like two
or three months it just looked weird it
would just didn't work so there's like a
weird moment um but i said screw it i
just want to see what's going to happen
so i got past like four months and then
started to pick it out and it had this
awesome shape to it one of the other
things more
more personal is my mom had cancer at
the time and
i said
you know if you ever lose your hair from
the chemo you can have my hair
and then she ended up she died eight
months later and i decided instead of
shaving my head like everybody else does
i just kept it um and and part of the
reason there's multiple reasons for
starting the channel i told you like i
wanted to get more jobs but one of them
was that
my mom was interested in photography she
always had an eye for
images she always took our pictures when
we were in disney and she had a beta
camera in the 80s a beta max
and she had an interest in learning and
i never
took the time to really teach her to say
mom let's go let's go shoot right let's
go to the park and do something and so
i i don't really do regrets the one of
the regrets i have the only thing is
that i never took the time to just say
let's go and shoot i was young i just
was stupid yeah i wasn't doing anything
else i should have just done it and so a
lot of people are like well now you help
teach the world you know you teach other
you've taught i've taught a ton of
people
how to take photos and then inevitably
make money doing that and change their
lives for the better and so that you
know
that's that's the hair
fro got it and then
do you cut it at all or at this point
you just keep letting it grow let it
grow let it grow let it grow how many
years is this
uh it was october 2007 okay when i had a
buzz cut because i went on tour in
september with perry farrell from jane's
edition yeah
that's kind of a buzz cut so we have all
the i have photos because i had a buzz
cut and it's been growing ever since one
little trim yeah then my mom got scared
and sent me to live with no will smith
too soon um
i had one trim job with a a person did
it and i looked like a jewish
grandmother
never never again so you're just always
gonna
how how is it not longer that's what i
thought because you said 2007. people
people ask that um i don't know i don't
know why it's not longer but it curls i
get really nice ringlets
it's a ringlet wrinkle
what's that girl's name
uh
from the movies
shirley shirley tom paul yeah okay yeah
the beautiful jewish curls as i will
call them um
i have no desire to cut it people are
like would you think you could still
have a channel i'm like yeah i could
still have a channel and not be froknows
photo but like sometimes i'll leave my
hair down in videos just to just to do
it
just to change it up and people are like
where'd your hair go
like yeah same hair i'm worried if you
didn't eat any
change to this that it would be less you
because this has become a bit of a brand
i think i'm at the point where it's okay
okay
it's so ingrained that
i it's not just the hair i think people
at the beginning are like this is just a
shtick
right they're like you're going to burn
out after eight months and no one's
gonna follow you anymore you're just a
guy with hair who
who does interesting things with cameras
or runs around the backyard and does
dumb [ __ ] but
still doing it yeah 12 years
and hitting the gym i see
these things those things yeah right
that's crazy we were supposed to leave
the guns at the front door but i brought
mine in too yeah
so i i attribute
um
right before i started youtube i i
wanted to i i photographed a fitness
conference
and
i was like i want to
look toned i was never overweight but i
was never
fit like toned and it's easy to find
trainers to help you lose weight it's
not easy to find trainers that help you
tone up and gain muscle
i found one i couldn't afford it we
worked out a payment plan and in 2009 i
just i started
going three days a week
i was making youtube videos so i had
time right i would go and i'd work out
and within two three months i was i was
toned and i was ripped two three months
it was qui it was quick it was like two
months it was quick i was dedicated man
i just went every day well two three not
every day three days a week but i
attribute the change in my body
giving me the confidence to be in front
of the camera because before that there
there's a video if you go to my if you
go to frodo's photo
youtube.com there's a when i hit a
million we did a retrospective video and
there's a video i did in 2008 where i
tried to make a video in my basement
talking about cameras and it's 10
minutes of me failing
hi
i'm no
uh
and it was just me going no and i would
just keep trying but i put the video up
yeah uh now just to show people i'm like
if if i could be that guy
and i turned into this and i'm able to
be in front of the camera
there's no excuse that you can't do it
because i went from that and that's why
i put the video out to show people that
i sucked in front of the camera and i
think what changed is i i i felt better
in my body for me like i do this for me
i don't do it's not it's not a show-off
thing i mean i do like the way they look
but it's not it's not for others it's
for it made me feel better yeah and so
i think that's what helped me be in
front of the camera and then and then
what is even worse is when i moved into
the city
uh in philly and i my trainer was 45
minutes away and i stopped doing it i'm
like i'm going to go to the gym myself
and then someone leaves a comment like
where did your arms go it's 2011.
i'm like and you know it's true which
[ __ ] sucks want to comment is
actually true you're like
[ __ ] so i made the commitment again i
was dedicated to i would drive out of
the city 45 minutes each way to go work
with the trainer two days three days a
week
because i want i didn't want to lose
them they were right but commoners are
souls most of the time and but that
that's the worst so like hit
pick something out and you're like
and you know it and it's just
it's terrible
but yeah that's that's the fitness alex
also tells me that you've maxed out your
credit card to start the business it is
true yes it was a zero financing card
for 15 months
hmm you hear that allies so what what
changes the story a little bit yeah
right what happened was it showed up to
my house with my name on it my dad's
house yeah
i think they thought they were sending
it to my dad but my name was on it and
it was what 2009. so they weren't giving
credit cards to people like me they
weren't given any credit cards after
that crash
there was a there was a zero financing
it was like fifteen 000 limit uh it was
for either i think was 12 or 18 months
and i did i started i put all the
t-shirts on there put all my expenses on
there i paid the minimums okay
i just i didn't carry i mean i carried a
balance but it was paid off by the end
that's how i started it i maxed i had i
had about 400 bucks in the bank and i
and i just put all the money on there
and i reinvested all the money back into
more merch so that i could get better
pricing
make more profit and it was paid off by
the end because it didn't hurt to get
the 20 some thousand dollars from
allen's camera right that helped pay it
all pay it all back but you know my
parents
always instilled in us like never carry
a balance
if don't buy it if you can't afford it
and it just it just made sense yep and i
don't care what they say but i don't
know if it's even true that if you pay
off your card every month that the
credit card company doesn't like that
well [ __ ] you credit card company i
don't give a [ __ ] that you don't like
that i don't like giving you 18 to 36
percent agreed was that was that too
much that was good are you even allowed
to curse on your show we do we we bleep
it right so most of the time oh my god
yeah why don't you say something earlier
i'm not sure it's fine
all this work no no no well alex isn't
editing this one
andrew you got to bleep that one uh no
it depends because sometimes we don't
want to stifle the guest and we feel
like if it comes out naturally it's
better not to have the guests think
about like not swearing and they can do
it so there's a kid around on there just
put a kid on the table i won't curse
yeah i'd rather you probably just swear
and we'll handle it yeah we'll handle it
yeah one of the big discussions i think
that uh jared and i had was uh
he
he's very adamant on not letting the
algorithm rule our life or rule his life
oh yeah this was a good conversation
something that in this household we
swear by the algorithms we have an
algorithm shrine in the living room
right so um yeah jared how come you
uh don't like deep diving into the
analytics and why don't you worry about
you know the algorithm uh because it may
benefit you or it may i just don't want
to because mentally it just becomes a
strain it becomes too much it's all i
think about and i don't want to i mean
obviously it's worked for you guys it's
it's clearly worked um
i just the the conversation we were
having was about changing the title
within 10 minutes of putting it up
based off of looking looking at numbers
and i've started to do that on occasion
alex but i don't like to to
to worry about it right we pick a title
we pick a thumbnail we think it's good
we go with it and if it's totally
flopping
maybe i'll switch it up to something
else but i just i don't want to
second-guess everything i do
and it just creates too much mental
strain for me and i just i don't want to
be beholden to that we we're good we
make money i'm happy yes i could make
more if if if we chase the algorithm i
just don't want to i don't what about
hiring somebody who then didn't make it
it's their problem yeah
algorithm yeah but then i don't i won't
listen to them
i won't listen to them but the thing is
you don't have to listen to them it's
you listen to the results like anytime
we post a video and it doesn't do well i
i never feel like oh man i screwed up
it's it's the audience giving me real
feedback right then and there that they
don't like that title thumbnail and
they're not clicking on it there's
nothing to do with the content like if
anything the fewer the people click on
the content the less it is about the
content and if your message is about
teaching people photography
there is an element that you want people
to see it who need to see that
of course so if you if you either do
that yourself or you hire somebody
and that's the it's just the audience
will tell you and usually 10 minutes is
long enough to say it's like is this
good or bad sometimes you know based on
your content like some will be too niche
and it's like it's not going to be yeah
so well part of the other issue is are
you chasing the right now views or are
you chasing views that might be long
term that you might be missing out on
over the long term it's a balance so but
you have to balance that right and we
have long like what i like to say are
long burned videos yeah a video that i'm
on a long day that's gonna freaking flop
yeah
but in four years we'll have like two
million views um it's all valid
i
i would try it i just don't i just i've
gotten to the point after 12 years of
doing it that
you know how a lot of people have burned
out in in youtube
i've never stopped in in the
12 years of doing it i've never gone a
week without putting a video up i even
got upset when i one day got to midnight
and didn't have a video ready to go and
put up a video every night or every day
and i had to get past that like my
following isn't going to disappear
because i don't put up a video for two
days and now we've gone to a place where
it's two or three or uh two or three a
week
yeah i mean i would i would like someone
to give me advice on what to do there to
see what could be better um
but i think we i think i had a downturn
in 2015 algorithm changed in 2015.
peter mckinnon comes along in 2015 a
bunch of other people come along in 2015
out of nowhere and start shooting up and
that that messed with my head i'm like
why are all these channels growing so
fast it's not like you know peter's
great the content that he does is
fantastic and he followed he did that
first video that went viral
he followed it with another video that
popped and he had like 50 000
subscribers but getting 200 000 views
youtube's like holy [ __ ] this is amazing
we're going to shoot this and it was at
2050 was the perfect storm he's in
canada and i always i told him this i'm
like i think you started to do part of
the benefit of being in canada less
competition for for the photography
world and if you rank high in canada
the algorithm is going to say well if
it's number one in canada we let's show
this to other people around the world
and it just skyrocketed um and in 2015
they started to downplay youtubers that
were around for a long time and i
started thinking do i build a new
channel
and try to capitalize on this do i kill
what i have and i took a look at the
content and some of it was i was just
putting out too much
so at the beginning it was put out a lot
of content because that was youtube it
was a different world
and then we started to put out better
con
still consistent but more quality spend
a little more time on each video put out
less
i wasn't thinking about titles very well
i'm like but this is what the video is
i'm just gonna call it this and that
wasn't working um and then we found our
way through it we started to make better
content and and we grew much more in
terms of views how many um employees do
you have and what is the workflow for
like a typical video look like
uh
so photo news fix is something that i do
weekly it's a
what i call a staple piece of content
that
averages 80 to 100 000 views for us
which is pretty good when when we went
from twenty to thirty thousand and then
fifty thousand to do a hundred thousand
is pretty good weekly for that um
i'll write that on a monday or a tuesday
and i'll film it on a tuesday i give it
to my editor and by wednesday after by
wednesday evening it's out by three
o'clock four o'clock um that's that's a
quick turnaround basically we say they
they my editors tell me that every
minute of video is about an hour of
editing
um so some long-form videos they take
maybe four five six working days to do
um we film them they take them they edit
them
and that's yeah two full-timers doing it
and how's your business broken down now
between
youtube sponsorships your own products
march good question youtube accounts for
like 112th
it's very
direct because i've done the numbers but
it's like 1 12 of the revenue we do
about 140 000 to 150 000
on on the youtube
ad rev
which is i know not a ton we're only
doing like anywhere from 1.2 to
1.7 million views a month it's not a ton
but we make it i cursed
darn it that's fine
um uh
we we do really well with presets
digital products uh there's squarespace
was the greatest deal i ever had
you made at the beginning um
they did an affiliate deal back in they
used to do affiliate deals back in the
day when squarespace was all over
podcasts
they they started to expand into the
youtube world
and we did a test and they offered me an
affiliate deal i'm like nah give me the
money
and i think it was like four grand and
then we did a test they wouldn't tell me
how many people signed up
and there were probably a lot so then
they came to me and they offered me uh
like
50 grand for the year for 20 video plugs
or something and the guy that gave me
the offered me the deal said don't take
it take the affiliate deal instead i
took the affiliate deal and that was
that's how i partly how i bought the
house too really yeah because
at the time this was like 2012 2011.
not a lot of people were promoting
squarespace not a lot of people had
their own website it wasn't easy to
build
i'm a photographer the people watching
me have photos they need to build their
own websites they don't want to go find
another
someone to build it because every time
you try to have someone build it you
have to reach out to them then they
never do the work and then you're stuck
and it was just such an organic way to
do i would do rapid fire critiques of
websites
and and i would say this is brought to
you by squarespace if if you have your
own photos and you'd like to build your
own gallery and you don't have your own
website this is easy it's like eight
bucks a month and you get a 14 day free
trial use my code fro at checkout and
you get 10 off your first order but look
you get 14 days i guarantee you
14 days it's gonna be easy build it
within 30 minutes you're gonna have a
site that's fully functional the
affiliate deal was interesting because
you don't get it you didn't get the kick
in the kickback once someone signed up
they had to stay a customer for three
months a paying customer most people
would say no i don't want to take that
deal because if i bring someone to you i
want to get paid as soon as they sign up
and i'm like i don't want to get paid
when they sign up i want to get paid if
they stay a customer that's good for you
that's good for me for the business like
for them and and i
it wouldn't be right if someone signed
up and then they cancel and i still got
paid but the first year we had
2090 signups
paying customers that stayed for three
months or more is 100 bucks a sign up
wow it was like
insane
that was the first year the last the
second year was like 184
000 and it just
it tapered down and now we just have a
we have a deal that they changed how
their structure is um and it still works
out well
so it's just it was just
a perfect time there weren't a lot of
people promoting it like they are today
or over the past couple years and it was
the perfect fit for my audience
and so that's why i was i was able to
generate a lot and yeah if i had more
subscribers and more subscribers it was
more people you can reach um but i i
just
i wanted to not have the burnout thing
like everybody else to be so focused on
everything eight months in when i
started youtube i was that was like the
closest i ever got eight months in at
the beginning i was like i can't sustain
doing two videos a day
and and this is impo with these
commenters this has heard it like i
don't know what to do
and i was such a small timer at that
time but yeah i just don't want to burn
out it's not even the burnout i just
don't want the stress yeah it's not
worth it
like i'm gonna try not to compare myself
to other people like peter's doing this
that that was one of the hardest things
is watch peter's growth
and i told him i'm like at one i'm like
me watching you go for fifty thousand a
hundred thousand and i'm watching my
subscribers and i'm looking at you
adding
you know five thousand subscribers a day
that was painful i've been working for a
long time look at his content and say i
wanna do something similar to that
because i remember him making very
specific content about like uh photoshop
tutorials
i remember one that i loved from him is
like how to photoshop out a person
and i watched that and that was like
that yeah i had stuff like that back in
the day what was he doing different i
thought he was like
welcome back oh you know yeah oh he
would be like very like he's likeable
he's super likeable he had he had the
magic he's got a great look he's got the
tattoos he has
a quality content shot extremely well so
very likable yeah i'm not very likable
i just rub people the wrong way um
and he and that algorithm change at that
time was very helpful he came around at
the perfect time and had great content
and followed it up with more great
content yeah and it just exploded
because it was good yeah and then
youtube's like we're just gonna keep
showing this to people while the other
people who made content
for a long time were like
hi i'm still here please help but part
of it was the content i was making
wasn't the right content right i was i
was starting to do not quality stuff and
so i had to
look within the stuff we were doing and
analyze and be like yeah yeah no you you
part of the reason is you're not
changing and so i've had to evolve like
every two years youtube seems to change
so it does yeah and so
i i've been doing for 12 years i'm happy
like i make
really we make great money my employees
have health care they have they get paid
well
um i have my properties would i like to
do more better sure i'm 41 i don't want
to work hard er harder i work really
hard but i don't want to work
harder yeah
i mean i don't know how long do i want
to do that do you have to do this how do
you avoid burnout though
because going 12 years a very long time
well the employees helped yeah you know
i edited the first couple hundred videos
and i haven't edited a video since
hiring my my first editor um
i just
how not analyzing everything that you go
into super detail on right like
analyzing every every s when youtube
changed to the studio where it's like
you're an apple this video isn't doing
well you need to do something different
i sent them an email like guys you
you're trying to have people not burn
out and you're telling us we suck with
these arrows saying our video isn't
performing well
and so it just made you that that was
that's bad because it makes you second
guess everything you're doing and then
try to change the title right away
i don't know i think it's helped because
i love seeing how my videos performed
over the last 10 and then seeing where
they rank and where they should rank and
and if it's not ranking where it should
then i know it's a title thumbnail issue
which brings up a a suggestion i gave
them and i'm sure plenty of people have
had i'm like why can't we have a b
testing of thumbnails and
and titles at the same time that it
launches
we put in two thumbnails we put in two
titles all different
you guys know within
within a thousand view you guys know
within seconds which one's performing
better
you'll make more money
i would love that yeah
i'm like guys figure it out like you
because
more more views helps us
but more views helps them sell more ads
i wish there was a way that you could do
that i would love that or before it
notifies everybody maybe you get like
ten thousand people yeah five thousand
dollars
five thousand this and people could sign
up and be a part of it and just see
which one gets more clicks and you could
go with that for the rest of them
after like 60 seconds they would know
after the first yes 500 clicks
they'd know that
473 people clicked on this type well it
wouldn't work like that but their nerds
would figure out how to make it work
that would be the the best thing for
for us then i wouldn't have to
second-guess everything because i hate i
would love second-guessing my stuff
that's why i try not to stress and
that's why i don't go in deep super deep
into the analytics i just i just won't
do it i don't
i'm happy
yes would i like to do better absolutely
of course but i don't i don't wanna i
don't wanna work that hard gosh if
youtube's watching this i would love
that i've told you that would be perfect
i told them that i know other people
have as well and i know there's there's
like two buddy and all those other
companies they offer you they're like
thumbnail split testing
but it only changes the thumbnail once a
day and it's after it already launched
so by the after 48 hours it doesn't
matter right i mean it does to some
extent but not for that initially first
i found it always it's always the first
one to two hours max that you could make
a meaningful change and then after that
sometimes i've done
drastic changes
and the views are the exact same so i
know after like two hours it kind of
locks in at least for that next day we
also know that sometimes the content
that we're putting out isn't doing well
because it's just not
meant to do well certain pieces of
content just aren't going to do well
certain lens review we know that a lens
review
for something like a new nikon lens
comes out we know it may not be a super
popular lens like you can't click bait
it in a and i i say click bait in a good
way because people again don't
understand titanic sinks 1 500 die is
that click bait when you see that on a
newspaper headline the answer is yes but
it delivers on the inside because
unfortunately 1500 people died when the
titanic sank right and
so where was i going clickbait
you have to click oh yeah the nikon
stuff um
the the
you can't click bait
the lens review
because it that's what it is it's a
nikon 100 to 400 review you can put
something at the end like this lens
sucks
right
but if you tried to clickbait it it
would be dead
and this this video will just make
get tons of views in the in the future
over here because lenses will stay for
five six years they'll stay new before
so before they replace it with something
else so people just keep searching those
out over time
so that's why i don't want to want to
come up with a clickbaity title for it
that's going to be dead after a couple
of days got it and i don't want to
change it too soon because it's it's not
meant to be a great it's not meant to be
a
a video for everybody it's for those
nikon people so you avoid burnout by not
looking at the numbers yeah those
numbers kill me
they do it's just too much
and and so i'm happier by not even
looking ignorant
you know what do you think about that uh
could you could you do that no
i i i look at all the numbers see to me
it's like uh like kind of playing a game
of chess
it's like you try to perfect the perfect
title thumbnail if it doesn't work
it's a race to try to fix it and get it
to something that works and i know some
videos are long tail and i know going in
okay this is going to be a 10. it's not
going to perform well 30 days in it's
good the 10. do more do people
understand that uh i talk about it so
often they do yeah
i've i've described i described those
tens yeah it's the worst performing
video that if of the last ten so 10 out
of 10.
um frustrating but yeah but but unless i
know going into it that this is going to
be a 10 i set the expectation i know it
but some videos i'll post and this
should be
much better this should get double the
views why
uh and i could see pretty quickly is did
i not get the click through from
notifications if not it's a title issue
then i'll change the title if i don't
see an immediate uptick within 10
minutes
thumbnail what's wrong with the
thumbnail change the thumbnail and so
two hours i'll usually have something
where i'm okay with it that's i mean it
works yeah i mean you get a ton of views
i just i so i don't crop for anybody
like images i don't crop my images
this leads into what we're talking about
the reason i don't crop my images in
this day and age is i don't want to
second guess every composition that i
take
and so it comes to the same thing with
the youtube videos i we we
we spend
sometimes an hour we spent a day on one
title once because
i just wasn't happy with what we were
coming up with and
i think it was we ended up with did i
fail
so we knew there's certain videos that
you just can't title right and it was a
video where we used a 60 000 microscope
to
uh try and get the grooves of a record
get a needle in the grooves of the
record i had to call olympus
i got them to send me down an 80 the 60
000 microscope with a technician to run
it to do this and it's a great video we
knew nobody would watch it if i wrote
taking a picture with a sixty thousand
dollar
microscope
and i didn't wanna put the well stephen
who i bounced the ideas off of didn't
like that i did a thumbnail that showed
what the final image was
because we found that if i'm not in the
thumbnail
it's people don't recognize same thing
if i posted a picture on instagram
that's a great picture but that people
don't know it's me because i i'm not in
it it doesn't get as many likes on it
but as soon as i post a picture of me
flexing and saying give me a comment or
like what am i thinking it's going to
get ten times the views it's
so annoying
um why didn't you just because you have
a sixty thousand dollar camera yeah find
a sixty dollar camera and then just
compare sixty dollar camera versus sixty
because okay the challenge was i had a a
a band member from a big band
say they have a new album coming and he
had an idea can i accomplish this
and oh that brings up a question you
asked earlier do i do shoots anymore
hold that thought
um i've been holding it yeah he um
he gave me a challenge i didn't know
what to do but i said yes because i'm
like yeah
i can figure this out and so that's
that's why i didn't get a 60 camera
because it's not possible to do it that
way um
but we went through the titles i didn't
like anything like
using a 60 000 microscope to do this uh
i didn't like the thumb steven didn't
like the thumbnail and he showed me one
in the video he's like use this screen
grab and it was just me looking off to
the side a tighter shot which normally
doesn't work and i'm wearing a mask
because it was during the pandemic and
normally people would just go nuts
because it's a mask um and then i was
like why don't we say did i fail because
it's not click bait because it was a
challenge
and we knew that we did that and it got
like a hundred and ten thousand views in
the first couple days that was a success
we knew that if we didn't do that it
would get 20 000 views yeah um so that's
what we had to do can i can answer that
question yeah because you brought that
back do i take jobs the answer is no i
tell people i cannot be hired
uh i say i will not be beholden to
someone else's expectations
but you still do shoot for i shoot what
no i shoot what i want you cannot pay me
you can pay me if you really want to pay
me and pay me well like
i just don't want to go through the bull
of back and forth of negotiating what i
think i know what i'm worth and having
people try to undervalue me i'd and then
tell me how to do my job i don't want to
do that so that's why i say i will not
be beholden to someone else's
expectations i shoot what i want i do
photo shoots for people um
because i love giving the gift of
photography i love being able to be in a
position where if i want to go
photograph my oldest fan
lawrence larry is 85
and he lives in uh owassa oklahoma and
he's been following my my channel for
like five years and he always comments
he's like i'm 82 and uh how do you how
do you think i should do this and that's
why i emailed the guy and i became a
friend with him just through email and i
said when the pandemic is
over which it never is
i will fly out and spend a day with you
and i flew out on my i didn't tell
anybody but i flew out on my own dime
and i'm like i'm gonna come spend some
time with you he picked me up at the
airport and uh i took photos of
everything i made a photo story i'm like
you sure you can drive like you're 85
you good and he's like i used to ride i
used to drive race cars and so yeah man
he was there picked me up we went to eat
um i spent a day and a half with him he
taught we played backgammon for like
five hours
um
and and and i then create a photo book i
always do i photo i love giving the
gifts so i make these photo books and
they're leaf behinds there's just
something that nobody's gonna throw out
when you give them the gift so i like to
do the shoots and then mail them this
book
and get their reactions to it because
they don't expect it uh and i just love
that
most people will never have a
professional photo taken of them they're
not used to seeing what quality is
especially with cell phones they're so
used to just garbage that when they see
quality they're like oh
that's the difference between a great
image and a snapshot
so
i like being able to
do shoots for people that may not be
able to afford it
and then i don't have to charge them and
they're like that's amazing so i can
pick and choose what i want to shoot and
people will give me they're like you're
not a real photographer because you make
your money doing something else and i
say isn't it the goal of every
photographer to get to the point that
you can shoot what you want when you
want to right like if it's a landscape
photographer why would you have to why
would you still shoot weddings if you
hate it just to make money so you can go
do the landscape stuff so if you make
money elsewhere there's nothing wrong
with doing
whatever whatever you want to shoot and
so
yeah can i be hired theoretically yes if
someone the right person came along and
was like and would pay me like to the 10
000 a day to do what i want to do
and leave me alone sure
um
but i like the thing i'm doing now with
the with the bowlers the professional
bowlers there's a guy named kyle troop
he has an afro on tour i sent him an
instagram message and i'm like i had it
first
and he's and then because i have the
check mark it's helped me get in touch
with a lot of people um and i'm like
look i want to do a photo story with you
and he's like well like what's that i'm
like so i explained i showed him some
other stuff and i'm like i wanna i'll
come out and photograph you all i ask
for is access you give me the access
i'll pay my flight i'll pay everything
um just give me access and i'm going to
give you the images to use however you
want it's like really
like yeah it's like well we'll be here
here and here i'm like all right i'll be
out for this tour for this stop and and
i did that that's how i've gotten access
to a lot of musicians um because
sometimes when musicians come to town i
have a bigger following than a lot of
them or some of them some of the the
mid-level bands and it's like
i'm gonna give you these photos
and i'm gonna make content and it
doesn't cost you money and i'm gonna let
you do stuff with it so that's how i get
access and that's how i get to shoot
what i want to shoot but i also can make
content out of it which then makes me
money so that i don't have to get paid
in the traditional sense of it because i
know i can make content out of it to
educate people and make revenue
i hope that answers that
but that's awesome i will not be
beholden to someone else's expectations
it's just something that
i just i've never worked
really i mean i've worked on nine to
five barely i just didn't last long
because i my dad
always worked for himself as a as a
sales schmata salesman close salesman
kids children's wear back in the day
and he always said that uh
his i will not be beholden to someone
else's expectations was i will not be
told when i can go take a piss
so he worked for himself
i like it i love it he says that wasn't
his quote but i'm like i'm pretty sure
that was your question
so yeah you never uh finished answering
the question how your business is still
broken down no a different question this
is graham's question because you you
said like 150 or whatever for the
youtube ad one
it's one twelfth that's
yeah you can figure out math okay that's
uh
1.7 million dollars one and a half it's
it's close yeah it's it's it's uh
it's
youtube revenue is nice like
i didn't care as much when it was like
forty thousand fifty thousand but when
you start making 150 000 extra dollars
just from ad revenue um it's a nice
chunk of change merch
don't really push merch that much
anymore because it's not as profitable
as selling a digital product when we
sell a preset uh preset pack for 90
and you're clearing 88
because that's less the fees that's a
hell of a lot easier to sell than
something you have to ship and and do so
we make a really nice amount with
digital products we make a nice amount
with uh you know the squarespace deals
um we have some other things we use
canon in the studio uh for video yeah
we we get uh
in in our videos it's we have a pop-up
that says this was shot with canon
cameras that's a
a sponsorship but they cannot tell me
what to shoot when it comes to stills
it's abundantly clear that no one can
pay me to use their gear i was a nikon
shooter from 15 to 38 years old two
years ago two and a half years ago
started using sony because it was the
right tool for the job and right now
i've started to use canon because it's
the right tool for me and so you cannot
you cannot buy me for for making a good
review i'm going to say you could pick
you want to pay me money you could pay
me money i'm just still saying it sucks
if it still sucks um and so
that that's that's the breakdown of the
revenue there's like six seven different
revenue streams um so if something goes
away you still have something else to to
to pick it back up but the digital
products
control your destiny your own destiny
it's just people that
try to make
if you have a large following and you
don't know how to monetize it
that you that's on you yeah right you
have to find a way to that's why comedy
channels were that failed in the past
because they didn't have the ability
what are you going to sell how to be a
comedian
right how to be funny
it just doesn't work
a joke
exactly
all right
is there anything else alex you think of
um
no not really do you do you want to rip
apart my photos no
i'm tired
do you want to do it right now or after
it's it's almost midnight yeah wait i
mean it's pretty late yeah what are we
at for time wise uh an hour 40. holy
that's okay that's long hours you're
watching hot in here your watch time is
gonna go down
why i don't know do people watch how
long do they watch these uh we've got 20
20 30 minutes yeah that's that's cool
yeah that's good but we've had we have
two and a half hour ones and people will
watch to the very end so do you put this
up as audio too audio uh it gets like 50
minutes average you or after watching
where do you hear that where where do
you what metrics
oh uh on anchor.fm oh you're using you
use libsyn yeah that's where you messed
up
we started out on libsync anchor didn't
exist when i started
so bad
but it was okay anyway i i think we're
good thank you for that thank you so
much i really appreciate you coming this
late
another right here there's a grammy
party for me to go to
is there actually the grammys are in
town wow someone texted me they're like
i'm putting you on a list i'm like
you could go there and get a free stock
when you sign up for public down below
in the description because that could be
worth all the way to a thousand dollars
with a good gram you don't like that i
love it join the mentorship group guys
link down below you can talk to graham
and i once a week you could never follow
me on instagram
you down below in the description if you
guys want to learn about photography
taking good videos and stuff like that
check out jared and with that said until
next time
cool thank you man really appreciate it
man